battle map so we will have the return of
ground war uh but we've got a new
large-scale mode that you've alluded to
right let's talk invasion
so invasion is it's a it's a big war map
it's like it's a big war tdm or we
affectionately call it the shipment of
ground war
it's 20 20 players but there's also 20
ai on each team
ai are coming in fast roping they're
coming in on medium birds
and it's this high action mode it's
super fun but it's also really chill the
announcer's not barking at you he's not
saying like hey get to b you know
they're taking c you can kind of play it
how you want to play it you sit up on a
rooftop and snipe you can grab a shotgun
and go room clearing if you push too far
into the enemy's base ai will come hunt
you
but we've also been really
conscious of where we put ai in
multiplayer um we didn't put ai in
killstreaks or anything like that
because we don't want ai showing up in
search and destroy we don't want ai in
domination this model however was built
for ai and it's a super fun mode can't
wait for people to try it kind of a
funnier side you know we took the name
ground war from a playlist in mw2 and
that was just large scale tdm and dom
and we kind of did the dom in the last
game and now we're able to add kind of
the sandbox tdm and so we're kind of
completing the cycle of that um that old
playlist yeah yeah this large-scale
stuff looks amazing this looks so so
awesome and uh okay so what about the
new 6v6 modes keep dialing it in closer
and closer stef what have we got yeah so
we also have two new 6v6 modes that
you're going to be seeing here displayed
today
and they will be in beta and prisoner
rescue and knockout prisoner okay let's
go into prison and rescue first joke
so prisoner rescue is an attack and
defend mode it's a round-based mode the
defenders have two prisoners they're
kind of spread out and they need to keep
hold of them the goal of the attacker is
to get to those prisoners pick them up
and carry them to ex-fill when you pick
them up you enter what's called a
wounded carry where they're up on your
shoulders and you can't use your primary
weapons instead you have to use a pistol
if you brought it or you're just stuck
with fists but the way that we give the
attackers an advantage once they grab
that prisoner is they get a radar sweep
for their team so they can call out
where the defenders are
and the objective icon over the prisoner
goes away as soon as they scoop them up
so now the defenders have to basically
rotate back to the x-fill and set up
defensive positions and it's this
heart-pounding adrenaline pushing like
mode once you grab that prisoner and try
and get them out
that hero run yeah
um definitely uh you know s and big s
and d energy in this mode um which i
resonates with me my time in esports so
this is my personal favorite of the new
ones and um also sort of the strategic
revives that happen there is a revive
mechanic and so you are able to to pick
up your teammates and
um i've seen some pretty pretty wild
comebacks in our play test so far
it was a lot of fun we got to play a
tiny bit yesterday was amazing
incredibly fun and i know the community
is going to love diving into over the
next week okay i can hardly believe that
there's actually a lot more content to
get through but there's one more thing i
have to bring up i have the honor of
officially announcing the third person
view is finally coming to modern warfare
2. uh what are the details behind this
one we got a little teaser of it uh on
on stage from patreo but what are the
details yeah you saw a little hint of it
in the trailer too um it's it's been a
pep project for us right we've always
wanted to do third person
and all while we're working on all this
other stuff we've been kind of lifting
up and doing third person in each mode
and the cool thing is that it's a
modifier on our game right we can just
turn on third person in the beta we'll
be playing it in hardpoint but we want
to try it post launch and snd we want to
try it in vr
um and we have
you know camera work the camera
collision's been reworked uh it handles
tight spaces there's a water camera
there's an interior camera you can feel
the weapon shake when you're firing with
it and it's just we've put a lot of work
into it we're excited for people to give
it a try incredible i can't really see
what third person card feels like in
2022 sexy skins and everything this is a
lot of information steph like there's a
ton here i tried to warn you they were
delivering a lot of new features for you
guys to try out ahead of release um and
i said we were going to be bold with
this beta and we are but there's even
more to come at launch so
this is just a taste how is this just a
taste how can there be even more i mean
we haven't even got to warzone
okay
okay so what about this year's third
mode so i'm happy to say that special
ops will return as our third mode and
we'll be focused on two player missions
asymmetrical in game design so think one
player on air support one player on the
ground and i think the og fans will be
really excited because we've looked at
you know some of the iconic modern
warfare missions like overwatch and and
really tried to um implement some of
those themes into
the design so uh we'll be talking more
about special ops in the uh in the
months to come stuff you're saying i
should be looking uh now for a special
ops partner sitting right next to you